can we talk about another exciting
another exciting space which is tissue
engineering
what is tissue engineering or
regenerative medicine you know so that
just to engineering regenerative
medicine have to do with building an
organ or tissue from scratch
so you know someday maybe we can build
the liver you know or make new cartilage
and also would enable you to you know
someday create organs on a chip which
people we and others are trying to do
which might lead to better drug testing
and maybe less testing on animals or
people organs and a chip it sounds
fascinating so what what are the various
ways to generate tissue and how do so is
it you know that the one is of course
from stem cells is there are other
methods what are the different possible
flavors here yeah well I think I mean
there's multiple components one is
having generally some type of scaffold
that's what Jay Vacanti and I started
many many years ago and then on that
scaffold you might put different cell
types which could be a cartilage cell a
bone cell could be a stem cell though it
might differentiate into different
things could be more than one cell and
that scaffold
sorry to interrupt it's kinda like a
canvas that it's a structure that you
can on which the the Susskind grow I
think that's a good explanation won't
you just an off to use that the canvas
that's good yeah so I think that that's
fair you know and the chip could be such
a canvas some could be fibers that are
made of plastics and that he'd put in
the body someday and when you see chip
do you mean electronic chip like
necessarily it could be though but it
doesn't have to be it could just be a
structure that's not not in vivo so to
speak that's you know that's outside the
body so is their emphasis it's not a bad
word says there possibility to weave
into the scanner as a computational
component so if we talk about electron
ships some some ability to sense control
some aspect of this growth process for
the tissue I would say the answer to
that is yes I think right now people are
working mostly on validating these
concepts for saying well it does work as
effectively or hopefully as just putting
something in the body but I think
someday what you suggested you certainly
would be possible so what kind of
tissues can we Jr today what would yeah
well yeah well well so skins already
been made and approved by the FDA their
advanced clinical trials like what are
called phase three trials that are at
complete or near completion for making
new blood vessels one of my former
students Lorin Nicholson led a lot of
that he thought that's amazing this
human skin can be grown that's already
approved through the entire the FDA
process so that means what so the one
that means you can grow that tissue and
do various kinds of experiments in terms
of in terms of drugs and so on but what
is that does that mean that some kind of
healing and treatment of different
conditions for on human beings yes I
mean they've been approved now for how
many different groups have made them
different companies and different
professors but they've been approved for
burn victims and for patients with
diabetic skin ulcers that's amazing
okay so skin what else well at different
stages people are like skin blood
vessels there's clinical trials going
now for helping patients here better for
patients that might be paralyzed for
patients that have different high
problems I'm you know at different
groups have worked on just about
everything new liver new kidneys I mean
there have been all kinds of work done
in this area some of its early but but
there's certainly a lot of activity what
about neural tissue yeah nurten the
nervous system and even the brain while
there have been people out of working on
that too we've done a little bit with
that but there are people who've done a
lot on neural stem cells and I know Evan
Schneider who's been one of our
collaborators on some of our spinal cord
works done work like that and ever been
other people as well as their challenges
for the when it is part of the human
bodies there's challenges to getting the
the body to accept this new tissue
that's being generated how do you solve
that kind of challenge there can be
problems with it accepting it I think
maybe in particular you might mean
rejection by the body so there are
multiple ways that people are trying to
deal with that one way is which was what
we've done and with Dan Anderson who's
one of my former postdocs and I mention
this a little bit before for a painted
pancreas is encapsulating the cell so
immune immune cells or antibodies can't
get in and attack them so that's a way
to protect them other strategies could
be making the cells not immuno genic
which might be done by different either
techniques which might mask them or
using some gene editing approaches so
they're different ways that people are
trying to do that and of course if he is
the patient's own cells or cells from a
close relative doubt might be another
way and it increases the likelihood that
they'll get accepted if you use the
patient's own cells yes and then finally
there's some you know suppressive drugs
which you know will suppress the immune
response that's right now what's done
say for a liver transplant the fact that
this whole thing works just fascinating
at least from my outside perspective
you